I don't even know why I think everyone
was just kind of like oh you're funny or
you know you just kind of so maybe that
were you funny like when you were you
know in high school anyone think of Ken
as the funny kid no quite frankly none
of my critics think I've ever been funny
so you know I don't think I'm waiting
for that to happen really you know you
know I had my coming-out party and being
funny
50 years of charm as they say but no III
really thought that I was just there's a
great line from waiting for Guffman as
Christopher Guest moving and where
Eugene Levy was a dentist he played a
dentist who was like who had a dream of
being a stage performer he goes I wasn't
the class clown as a kid but I studied
him and so that was I felt like I was a
kid like yeah like I loved comedy but I
was a stressed out kid just trying to
trying to get into a good school
that really was me in a nutshell I was
just trying to do my best in every every
class I had and I was really too
stressed out to be a class clown I
wasn't relaxed of because part of comedy
is being relaxed and I I don't think I
was relaxed as a kid so then you got to
do you take this acting class did you do
any improv comedy or anything like that
through your college career no I kind of
we part of theater is doing improv
acting exercises and I just so I would
improvise in certain acting games that
we would have and and I just had a
natural proclivity towards comedy and
even then I mean and then I started
doing musical theater and they have a
really great musical theater company
hoof and horn at Duke and so I would do
that I would do hoof and horn and and
then dude and then I was I actually
applied to drama school and I got
accepted really yeah and but they were
that's where I had my crisis of
of a crossroads because there was a fork
in the road because I was either going
to go pre-med and and continue on
because I was taking organic chemistry
of my sophomore year and then I or I
could go into drama class where you have
to tell you you have a drama lab your
whole life is basically it is all drama
I mean all your courses all your
electives everything's geared so and I
remember the head of do drama saying we
think you could do both and then and I
was like no there's no way I could do no
I'm not smart enough I don't have the
bandwidth I'm not that you know
incorrect incorrect I even even at 18 19
years old I was painfully aware of my
limitations and I knew that I did not
have the natural aptitude to fully
maximize potential in both areas so it
was really hard man I made a very
difficult choice after discussing with
my parents and of course they were like
you know you know go with something I
mean your parents didn't come down hard
for theatre
you instead of waiting instead of
waiting for godot you should wait on
you're pre-med know